Susan page is the Washington bureau
chief for USA Today she's watched 17
Supreme Court nominations including the
Clarence Thomas Anita Hill testimony in
1991 Susan good morning good morning
first let's where do you think the
Cavanaugh nomination was headed before
all of this and where do you think it
sits now just in terms of counting noses
so it was on its guide path to to
confirmation there's no question about
that
Democrats had failed to get traction
against him although they opposed him I
think it was likely he was going to hold
all the Republicans and perhaps get two
or three Democratic senators are up for
re-election and Trump states that's
entirely changed now his nomination
really hangs in the balance on what
happens today one of the things
Republican senators have chosen to do is
have somebody else ask the questions for
them which is an extraordinary thing in
Washington for senators to choose not to
speak in front of a microphone but this
will not stop them as they say in the
law from speaking after that it is over
so give me your sense of the political
risk for Republican senators after this
is all over
regardless of what we hear I think
Republican senators are fooling
themselves if they think they escape the
political risks because they have
someone else actually doing the
questioning they're still going to be
responsible for what they say afterwards
for the kind of questioning he has that
the prosecutor presents to that dr. Ford
and and what happens whether Americans
believe judge Kavanagh or dr. Ford is
going to determine how they assess how
Republican senators have proceeded in
this case listen we have seen dramatic
hearings on Capitol Hill before but
certainly nothing like this because this
is there's so much more at stake than
just a Supreme Court seat is it not oh I
think absolutely and also it's the
Supreme you know if judge Kavanagh is
very convincing today and dr. Ford looks
tentative or uncertain are they not
coals in our story they will have a
committee vote tomorrow and he will make
it to the Supreme Court but if the
reverse happens if she's compelling and
convincing and he seems uncertain he is
not going to make it to the court and
this isn't just any Supreme Court suit
that's cheap this is the swing seat if
he gets on this court it's going to
solidify a conservative majority what if
they're both convincing today's and then
what
what yeah and then I think we continue
to have a debate about who do you
believe whether there should be more of
an investigation and where the
Republicans are prepared to as senator
Mitch McConnell said plow on and just
push this through superfast there are
Democrats in Trump States who are up
what do you think their political
calculus is and how many of them are
there who might really be up in the air
about Cal I think that ended when these
allegations surfaced who gave them a
reason to vote no and I think they are
no longer on such such tender hooks
about whether to support him or not all
right Susan page always good to see you
thank you